new possible issue along the lines of it's not the
crime, it's the cover up potentially afflicting
Donald Trump. It is now being explored whether
Trump provided doctored Mar a Lago security
footage. Now, let me back up and remind you what
this is about. We saw Trump's Mar a Lago home,
some call it raided. A search warrant was served.
People often get very upset if you use one term or
the other. They are often used interchangeably.
A search warrant was indeed served at Mar a Lago
related to classified documents that Donald
Trump was asked to return, and he didn't.
And it's a major, major investigation that
we've talked about before. One aspect of this
is security footage, and there are now questions
as to whether parts of the security footage were
removed or doctored by people working for Donald
Trump. A couple articles about this Esquire
report, special Counsel Jack Smith has a few
questions from Mar a Lago Security, for example,
what happened with the handling of surveillance
footage they subpoenaed? Charlie Pierce wrote this
article and says, Lordy, there may be doctored
tapes, at least according to senior CNN special
counsel Jack Smith has his special suspicions,
quoting the handling of the footage and how
employees within the Trump Organization responded
to the Justice Department's demand for it have
prompted a new round of grand jury subpoenas to
top Trump employees in the last few weeks, sources
told CNN. Longtime Trump Organization executive
Matthew Calamari and his son Matthew Calamari Jr,
are expected to appear before the grand jury
investigating possible mishandling. Prosecutors
are expected to ask them about the handling of
the surveillance footage and trump employees
conversations following the subpoena. Possible
mishandling is prosecutor ese four We've got these
techies, you see, and they're very good and they
have some questions. The question here is about
whether the video surveillance footage was indeed
doctored. Yahoo News sorry. CBS News via Yahoo!
Life also writes about the security camera video
from Trump's Mar a Lago resort under scrutiny.
So we've heard this term before. This term, it's
not the crime. It's the cover up that really could
play a major role here. And in fact, as we've
talked about before, this has really been a theme
of much of the many of the troubles that Donald
Trump has had since he became president. Even if
we go back to the Mueller probe, the Russia probe,
as Trump calls it, Russia, Russia, Russia, if from
day one, Trump merely said, I will cooperate
with your investigation, we did nothing wrong.
I am now president. I'm focusing on running
the country and I will not be making any
public statements in order to not prejudice or
influence or meddle with this investigation. 90%
of the Mueller probe would not have taken
place. A lot of what ended up happening
was self-inflicted because Donald Trump
couldn't keep his mouth shut. And similarly,
you know, you've got the handling of the documents
themselves and that would be adjudicated,
investigated, potentially adjudicated in the
future. But if indeed the security footage
showing documents being moved around shows
that the documents were deliberately hidden,
then you've got layer one of the cover
up, and then if you've doctored the
security footage of you trying to hide the
documents related to the original inquiry,
we've now have we have a second layer of cover up
which could play a major role. So we will watch
it. That's the latest suspicion from the special
counsel and we will see what comes of that.